how much money do you need to quote
unquote make it some of you guys may be
saying one million dollars while others
are saying one billion dollars something
that we can all agree on though is that
if you have 35 billion dollars you've
definitely made it right well that's
exactly what ike batista thought in late
2012 ike was the richest man in brazil
with a net worth of 35 billion dollars
and he thought that he had made it in
fact he teased carlos slim the richest
man in the world at the time that he
should watch out because ike was coming
for him yet just six months later ike's
net worth plummeted to 200 million
dollars and by early 2014 ike found
himself with a negative net worth of 1.2
billion dollars so here's how ike lost
everything in a matter of months
taking a look back ike batista was born
on november 3rd 1956 in governor d'or
validaria's brazil his father elizabeth
batista was a native brazilian
businessman who served as the minister
of mines and energy
meanwhile ike's mother was from germany
and she spent her time raising ike and
his six siblings ike spent most of his
childhood in brazil but his family would
move to europe when ike was a teenager
due to his father's work during their
time in europe the family lived in
geneva dusseldorf and brussels his
family actually moved back to brazil
when ike turned 18 but ike decided that
he wanted to stay behind and enroll in a
european university in 1974 ike enrolled
in the university of atkin in germany
and began pursuing a metallurgical
engineering degree it doesn't look like
i experienced paid for his education
though at least not fully as ike had to
sell insurance policies door-to-door to
sustain himself in germany ike later
revealed that the stress of trying to
make a living selling insurance was one
of the most valuable parts of his
academic career
anyway ike returned to brazil in the
early 1980s and set his sights on the
mining and trading industries at age 23
ike founded a gold trading company
called atrum aurum ike wasn't doing
anything revolutionary he was simply
buying gold from producers in the amazon
and selling it to buyers in european and
brazilian cities despite the simplicity
of the endeavor it was extremely
successful the company earned 6 million
within just the first 18 months of
operations though the company was
growing rapidly ike didn't just want to
be a middleman forever so he founded a
gold binding company called the ebx
group and to give himself an advantage
against competitors ike brought modern
technology to gold mining with the ebx
group ike created the first mechanized
alluvial gold mining plant in the amazon
a couple of years later ike expanded his
mining operations internationally with
the founding of tvx gold which was based
in canada ike would take the company
public on the montreal stock exchange
shortly after but this was a move that
he later regretted in the meantime
though things were going great
by the end of the century the ebx group
was operating eight gold mines in brazil
and canada and a silver mine in chile
and these mines had produced a total of
20 billion dollars worth of value since
their creation
this made ike quite wealthy but he still
had a ways to go before reaching
billionaire status
in the 2000s ike opened a company after
company and diversified into as many
industries as he could for example in
2001 ike founded mpx which was a power
generation company based in rio de
janeiro a few years later in 2005 i
created mmx which focused on mining and
trading iron ore in brazil and chile
similarly in 2007 ike founded llx which
focused on providing logistics to ike's
other companies but by far his most
ambitious and daring endeavor was ogx
with ogx ike aimed to create a global
oil producing giant based in brazil
in 2007 ike started searching brazil and
he eventually landed on an oil reserve
with 1 trillion worth of deposits to put
that into perspective saudi arabia's
natural resources add up to 34.4
trillion dollars
so ike wasn't going to dethrone the real
oil giants anytime soon but 1 trillion
worth of deposits was still a massive
discovery ike took the company public in
june of 2008 raising a record 4.3
billion dollars and this is what pushed
him over the edge to billionaire status
around the same time ike founded one
more company called osx in 2007 which
focused on building ships with all these
companies up and running ike turned his
focus onto growing these companies you
might have noticed that all of his
companies end with the letter x which
was on purpose ike believed that the x
implies multiplication and exponential
growth and that naming scheme was pretty
accurate as his companies exploded in
the late 2000s and early 2010s
much of brazil and the media love dyke
because of his extreme brazilian pride
ike strongly believed that brazil was on
the brink of an economic boom and that
it was his duty to lead brazil to the
next level
ike wasn't some saint or anything but he
did everything he could to earn brazil
positive press
in 2009 for instance ike played a key
role in helping rio de janeiro win the
bid for the 2016 olympic games aside
from his strong brazilian pride ike had
massive pride in himself as well
ike believed that he was going to become
the world's richest man by 2020 with a
net worth of 100 billion dollars
and given that he was worth 35 billion
dollars and the seventh richest person
in the world this was honestly a pretty
realistic goal for him unfortunately
though fate had a different idea
despite ike's rather positive public
persona there was a group of people that
despised them for his business practices
his company mmx breached a slew of
environmental regulations and had been
fined several times
mmx was also accused of bribing and
coercing a native indian group off their
land in 2008. that same year brazilian
police raided ike's homes and offices in
an effort to find evidence of gold
smuggling and tax evasion but they were
unable to find any evidence so while ike
had some red flags here and there they
weren't too concerning
unfortunately there wasn't much time
left when the major red flags came up
in late 2012 gold had a flash crash
gold plummeted from 1800 an ounce to
1200 an ounce within just a few months
this was the first time that gold had
crashed during ike's career gold had a
similar run-up and a crash in the late
1970s during the inflation crisis
but since ike started mining and trading
in the early 1980s gold had more or less
just gone sideways or up
in the meantime silver got crushed even
harder between 2011 and 2013 silver
prices plummeted from 1500 per kilogram
to 650 per kilogram and silver still
hasn't recovered no one really knows
what specifically triggered this crash
in precious metals
it's agreed upon that once the selling
started computer algorithms started
dumping positions and this works in the
sell-off but we don't really know what
triggered the initial sell-off there is
speculation that big banks triggered the
sell-off in order to accumulate at
cheaper levels but that's not confirmed
whatever the reason though ike's
companies instantly felt the pain of
this flash crash his mining and trading
companies started losing hundreds of
millions of dollars if this was the only
issue i think i could have handled it
however ike was about to face another
massive blow with his oil company ogx
ike had promised that his oil company
would pump 750 000 barrels per day but
there was a massive problem since
founding the company brazil had chosen
to nationalize oil production which
meant that ike no longer had access to
the 1 trillion oil deposit he discovered
ike was optimistic that he could still
make ogx work by drilling for oil in
parts of brazil where it was still
allowed but at the end of the day ogx
was only able to pump 15 000 barrels per
day which is a far cry from the promised
750 thousand
after seeing these disappointing numbers
investors fly to ogx stock and ike
struggled to fund the money losing
company ike says that if he had kept his
companies private and relied on private
investors they likely wouldn't have
dumped their positions as aggressively
and while that is likely true private
investors likely wouldn't have bid up
his company so much in the first place
so ike might have had less cash to run
his companies if he chose a private
route ike started selling off his assets
to try to keep the company running for
example ike sold most of llx to a u.s
investment group for 559 million dollars
but given that everyone was dumping all
of his companies it was extremely
difficult to raise enough money to keep
ogx afloat all of these pressures peaked
in october of 2013 when ogx defaulted on
a 45 million interest payment and at the
end of october ike had no choice but to
give in and let ogx file for bankruptcy
just 12 days later osx would also file
for bankruptcy
at this point ike's massive conglomerate
of companies had shrunk into just mmx
and mpx and ike's liabilities far
outweighed his assets which gave him a
net worth of negative 1.2 billion
dollars mmx and mpx stayed alive for the
time being but these would also crumble
over the next few years
in december of 2014 mpx filed for
bankruptcy and mmx followed behind in
november of 2016. ike's financial
success was gone but soon his personal
freedom would be taken away as well
with this money and influence gone
brazilian regulators decided to crack
down on ike in january of 2017 ike was
arrested and thrown in prison by
brazilian authorities for money
laundering and bribery can you believe
that just five years ago ike was the
seventh richest person in the world but
now he was in jail ike was sentenced to
30 years in prison for laundering 100
million dollars and bribing the former
governor of rio de janeiro with 16.6
million dollars to give his company's
government contracts
on top of this he was also convicted for
insider trading ike didn't actually
spend 30 years in prison though ike's
lawyers would appeal the verdict and
work out a plea bargain
in march of 2020 ike agreed to pay 160
million dollars and give up everyone
associated with the money laundering and
insider trading schemes at this point
most people would just stay out of the
public's view and live the rest of their
lives under the radar but this is not
the case with ike batista in october of
2020 ike announced that he was going to
restart mmx and get back into the mining
business
ike says that he's going to pay back all
of his debt and that he's going to rise
to the top once again
ike's unbeatable spirit is definitely
something to admire but we'll have to
see how well a second try at
entrepreneurship goes at the end of the
day ike had a massive empire on his
hands but it looks like he bit off more
than he could chew
and as soon as the market and policies
turned against him his empire crumbled
hopefully he doesn't make the same
mistake once again
do you guys think ike can make a
comeback and return to 35 billion
dollars comment that down below
also drop a like if you admire ice
resilience and of course consider
joining our discord community to suggest
future video ideas and consider
subscribing to see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one